dialog with with ecology with nature as
interests and like our view of like what
what the kind of indigenous peoples and
like the idea of the shame and our view
of what the shaming is is so skewed by
our kind of Western mode then yeah what
they're there tapping into is not like
it isn't the supernatural that's not
sort of the that's not really the mode
what you have and you still have it in
these indigenous peoples that sort of
say live like a rural Asia and so on
that where these these these ways of
living is still going on is what's
what's clear is it's not the
supernatural it isn't the spirit it's
it's all about a really easy
relationship with the natural world so
an example of this is a great book
called the spell of the sensuous by
David Abrams who actually was a magician
originally who went out and lived
amongst his people and he he talks about
this and he said there was he was
staying in this compound this shaman's
compound and the the shaman's wife would
bring him some fruit every morning but
she also had these little like banana
leaves with rice in and she would she
was going off and doing something else
with those and he asked where they were
going and he said all those of her the
spirits at the house right so what and
then she'd come back and without them
she was just wondering kind of what that
meant and what he was doing so one day
he just kind of followed and watched her
and she was placing these little pockets
of these little things of rice out
around the perimeter of this compound
and he was watching him and from a
distance and he saw the rice start to
move and he had a moment of like oh this
is the spirits what is this and then the
rice moved along the ground and you know
it's ants
it's ants so what she's actually doing
she's putting out rice for the ants so
then he had the thought of a Widow's and
spirits it's just ants and then you
realize no of course the ants kind of
are the spirits right so this is a house
where food is prepared where they have a
lot of fun of big events and an ant
infestation would be just disastrous for
them so the spirit that the offering to
the spirits of the house is a kind of a
dialogue with the answers gone if we
we're going to put this rice out can you
just if you just have the rice if we do
this every day will you leave us alone
and and then you that's it like it's
it's kind of thats it's quite simple
dialogue and I sort of this lovely kind
of embodied relationship with nature
that of course we're so far from here
and so interestingly we do tend to pack
a lot of ideas into the you know the
supernatural even like the unconscious
and depth psychology and so much I'm a
big fan of but we can take all this the
unknown stuff and shove it into these
kind of bottomless pits or is actually
interestingly if you trace it back it
seems like it just wasn't like that it
was this very yeah what doesn't it
depend on what they're doing is
particularly with shamans if a shaman is
concentrating on psychedelic drugs
they're an ayahuasca Church and they're
giving people dimethyltryptamine like
this is the they are dealing with the
supernatural that's a very bizarre and
intense transformative experience
they're putting people through yeah and
there's different like that term shaman
it really it kind of was very rare very
rare to be discussed up until about
maybe 20 plus years ago yeah and it
seems like there's been some sort of a
psychedelic revolution over the last
couple of decades and it's almost become
a little bit too popular here where a
bunch of people are profiting from it or
they're they're opportunists and they're
they're labeling themselves as shaman I
think the term that they use in Peru
they call them plastic shaman and
they're setting up shop and putting
together this ayahuasca brew and having
all these Americans come in flying in
Europeans or you know air-quote
spiritual experience and these are not
necessarily pure shaman and the greatest
sense of the word it's a different this
is what we think of when we think of
shaman today we think of someone who
conducts a psychedelic ritual